hello i'm mateus left confirm the world
coming forms media team and responsible
for social media activities at the forum
i'm here at the Davos debates corner
with ring kasese who brought you all the
Presidents and Prime Minister and Royals
to this edition of the Davos debates the
annual meeting of the world economic
forum is finished and we would like to
thank the entire YouTube team will
helped us set up this amazing experiment
so i'll start off the number the names
it's thanks to steve's thanks to child
jeff lee Olivia Tom rush nuh and Robert
and I'm sure I'm forgetting a couple and
the big thank you also to Julia la de
Mirage who won the Davos debates this
year and she brought the her cause the
fight against female genital mutilation
to Davos her panel that was here here
yesterday is up on this channel you must
watch it is very amazing how cheap you
know kind of really starts her cause and
reignite of course absolutely brilliant
panel you Muslim should watch this the
devil's debates are not finished they
will continue at all our regional events
this year we will be in Vietnam in
Morocco we will be in Tanzania Africa we
will be in India and in China so hoping
to continue this discussion with you
thank you very much for all your
questions and videos and signing off
from Davos